[Music]
my name
is makoynatos i am the commander of the
free navy
with the opening of the alien gates we
are at the crossroads no longer will
belters be persecuted
with this attack we will show our
oppressors a stink thing
never thought possible the future of the
boat
has begun
nothing's ever going to change you've
got to stop focusing on the end of the
world
you've got a ship of your own a good
crew
someone who loves you and you love
you're not responsible for the world
why are you going back to earth i have
personal business in baltimore
this place ashford's ship i never
thought i'd actually find it we have an
opa informant
this is your son i chartered a freighter
bound for palace
i have to go find phillip i was always
waiting for you to turn up this world is
messed up
float to the top or sink to the bottom
everything in the middle is a churn i
have information that inaros intends to
attack
civilian targets i don't know if it's a
single huge conspiracy but someone high
up in the chain of command is in on it
this is not my fight marco has millions
of voters
if you go toe-to-toe with him we could
you have lose the entire belt to war
with the inners
they wanted to fight we'll give her one
it's time to take the roster out for a
hunt
do your stuff fly boy
a century of leaders have promised he's
gonna unite
a hundred separate factions
into one nation
it's time to let the system know
who we are
[Music]
you